I'm gonna ask you about how you cast
Christopher and how he has Peter when
you are thinking about who's gonna play
this fictionalized version of your
father what were the things that were
important in terms of performance in
terms of personality that you wanted to
see in this character I just wanted to
see you know my father does not look
good on paper right he's just in and out
of prison he's gotten to a lot of
trouble doesn't pay taxes in and out of
his kids lives and six he's been married
six times so he doesn't look great on
paper but when you meet him if any of
you had met him he'd sit down with you
during some tequila tell you the story
about how he you know used to go into
casinos he invented the solution that
you would mark cards with you'd put it
on your fingertips and he'd mark cards
with a solution and he was wearing
special eye contact lenses that could
see that solution on the card so he knew
when an ace was coming up or something
like that yeah he was great with cards
and so you know college education was
paid for in big envelopes of cash that
he would send so I think if you you know
if you saw him and you met him you'd
really fall in love with him and like so
many people did so many wives did and
you know Christopher Plummer couldn't be
further from my father you know my
father is covered in tattoos and you
know in and out of prison from El Paso
Texas
you know drove a pickup truck most of
his life and so when his Christopher
Plummer his name was first mentioned I
kind of looked at my casting directors
like okay let me let me think about that
that's a plight thing you say right let
me think about it and then I watched
some interviews with Christopher Plummer
and I thought my god is this guy
charming Wow he is so charismatic I mean
I knew he was just a stellar stellar
actor but when I saw those interviews I
just knew yeah they had that same spark
all that same twinkle in their eye Peter
you've worked with Christopher before
tell us about working with him now and
your first meeting with him actually I
that was the first time I'd worked with
Christopher in boundaries but I've known
him since I was 18 and I was able to use
that
in that initial greeting when I'm
hogging him and throughout because I you
know I've just used it had fun with it
and he is charming he is terrific and
for me when I read the script I know I
knew Christopher was involved and I
loved the script because it was very
funny and in this particular road trip
I'm not the traveler I'm the campfire
tables have turned and being you know
being there at the campfire for
Christopher to come and I mean I've said
this in shelter I mean say this I
consider Christopher to be the finest
Shakespearean actor in the Americas you
know so given that the final
Shakespearean actor in the America is a
selling pot to Easy Rider this is
terrific
absolutely I wanted to get part of the
Hat and it was fun you know we had a
good time it was a tough shoot we had a
lot of stuff to do you know Jonah was
shooting in basically a television shoot
in terms of schedule we had just the
Nessus is per day and in terms of how
many has you had to shoot how many pages
you had to get through what was your
schedule yeah we you know you we I did
not cut this script down which I should
have I was way too precious so we were
shooting ten pages a day yeah what do
you give them as a director to let them
act
I mean how married are you to the words
you've written and how much we let them
bring what it is they can do Joe Peters
awesome at improv you know he's so much
fun
if Peter Unleashed I have a four hour
movie because he gives it he has a lot
of gold that he gives in the improv
stage that's really hilarious but you
know there's a part of me that when I
was directing Peter Fonda and
Christopher Plummer saying it out loud
just feels so unnatural I was terrified
you know what can I add to their
performance like it almost felt rude to
direct them you know like I still do you
know any kind of suggestion would be
like what why and what're ya working so
I I had to get rid of that and I think
you made that really easy on me and of
course Christopher was too but
um I still you know even when you're in
Chicago I just I there were times where
I was like whose life is this that I get
to work with you I just felt really it's
just a really cool thing you know I'm so
I'm just an actor you know I listen to
your stories he has such amazing stories
and oh what an incredible body of work I
mean that's why everybody's here so it
thank you
well I have to thank you I'm shot I was
very good in her direction and her crew
she had a really good company which is
always a pleasure to shoot with a good
company and when we were doing the last
scene where the two hitmen come in hit
boys hit boys well you know and Sean
said okay now just take it wherever you
want to and actors like to hear that
from time to time especially if we're
comfortable in our roles and for me the
playoff was where Christopher and I are
up against the glass wall and the guys
are saying where's the where's the weed
where's the money where's the week and I
didn't know I thought well how the [ __ ]
would I know I'm stoned out of my head
and Vera behind me started laughing off
camera and the Gumby the camera crew
would laugh - it was a very you know it
was intense work but it was also fun
Shauna when you're thinking about the
kinds of people you want to have as
department heads what were the important
factors to you what kind of family did
you try to create around this production
well I you know I really wanted to work
with as many women as possible which was
actually surprisingly difficult it was
really important to me that I got to
work with Sarah but as far as my sets go
I don't think you have to have the worst
experience to make a good movie
I know people tell you that receive well
you know you're having a horrible
experience on film and people like this
is gonna be a good movie you know
because everybody's miserable and wants
to kill each other and yelling at each
other I don't think that has to be right
but I just like collaborators you know I
I think this is this film really got
gave me a chance to
be selfish with who I chose to work with
I got to work with all of my first
choices as far as caste and that only
made me look like a better director and
as far as my crew and my heads of
department
you know they I'm I think I'm an actress
director that's where I have the most
fun so it's really important for me to
trust completely everybody that I'm
working with and in this case I really
they did make me look a lot smarter your
father did not live to see this film in
your mind if there was something that he
could have taken away from it what would
those that thing or those things have
been to know that you had succeeded in
telling the story that you wanted to
tell sorry guys god sorry I just I hope
that um my love for him is on the screen
I think his portrait that I captured
really he's a guy with a handlebar
mustache if you didn't catch that but I
think that captured his spirit and his
humanity and I'd love for him to take
away I'd love for him to know that
people will hopefully rescue animals
after they see this film maybe but
forgiveness and that's that's huge to me
that my heart is just full of love for
him and I have totally forgiven him
thank you so much for saying that Sean
and Peter thank you